madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
de l'actualité de ce jeudi 29 juillet de
leurs championnats d'europe de natation
après la roumanie
roxana maracineanu ce sont franck
esposito sur 200 m papillon et stéphane
perreault embrasse qui décrochent les
médailles d'or à istanbul du jamais vu
depuis longtemps une étape capitale dans
la lutte contre le cancer des chercheurs
américains découvrent les phases de
transformation d'une cellule normale en
cellules cancéreuses
un événement phare dans la recherche qui
devrait se traduire à long terme par
l'arrivée de nouveaux traitements
week-end de tous les dangers pour bison
futé 7 millions d'automobilistes sont
attendus sur les routes pour un chassé
croisé qui s'annonce difficile pour
éviter les ennuis laisser passer le
samedi c'est le slogan de la sécurité
routière
hubert védrine son entame une visite de
travail de deux jours à alger un moment
qui doit contribuer au réchauffement des
relations entre paris et alger les
algériens attendent des gestes concrets
de la part de ministres des affaires
étrangères et puis nous irons avignon
sur un air de tango le spectacle tango
valse tango kloet en effet le 53e
festival d'avignon sur fond de réussite
cette année avec 15 % de fréquentation
en plus mais commençons ce journal par
la natation il faut n'est pas coutume
les français en sont à leur troisième
médaille d'or aux championnats d'europe
à istanbul
du jamais vu depuis longtemps les
médaillés du jour s'appelle franck
esposito et stéphane perreault nathanaël
de rincquesen à istanbul
les nageurs français ont le sourire
à l'image de franck esposito
il navigue sur une vague de médaille
après roxana maracineanu avant-hier
franck esposito ramène à son tour un
titre de champion d'europe celui du 200
m papillon une course n'est pas finie
parce qu'on touche le mur donc j'essaie
de m'accrocher se régule mal mais je
pense que les deux autres ont eu mal
aussi donc le plus fort l'emporté le
support là peut être emporté mais il a
eu beaucoup de mal dans les remous du
bassin d'istanbul
esposito de vence le oui si l'ancien
champion du monde en titre 2 seulement
neuf centièmes de seconde
galvanisés par ce succès les autres
nageurs français se déchaînent en finale
du 200 m brasse
perreault et bernard ne sont pas favoris
il se retrouve pourtant rapidement au
premier plan de la course stéphane
perreault s'impose aisément et améliore
le record de france johan bernard 8
décroche la médaille de bronze stéphane
perreault voit une grande place de
bonheur
lorsque les deux français quittent le
bassin les discussions vont bon train
première sélection déjà cinq médailles
et les championnats d'europe ne sont pas
finis ça promet un an des jeux de sydney
elle vous ai parlé de la roumaine roxana
maracineanu il s'agit bien sûr d'une
française d'origine roumaine
c'est sans doute la plus grande
découverte sur le cancer depuis ces
dernières années des chercheurs
américains ont réussi à décrypter les
quatre phases au cours desquelles une
cellule normale se transforment en
cellules cancéreuses les milieux
scientifiques par l'adp étape capitale
dans la compréhension du cancer et à
pernes dans les méthodes de traitement
les explications de marc maisonneuve et
de jean-jacques le garrec
comment se transforme une cellule
normale en cellules cancéreuses depuis
15 ans les chercheurs étaient face à un
mur jusqu'à aujourd'hui
jusqu'à ce que le biologiste américain
robert weinberg trouve le secret de la
transformation le dérèglement des gènes
l'origine du cancer avec cette
multiplication anarchique des cellules
pour la première fois on a pu étudier
les cellules cancéreuses humaines à
travers leur code génétique
c'est quelque chose qui n'avait jamais
été fait avant car jusqu'à présent les
chercheurs savaient faire cela avec des
souris mais pas avec des cellules
humaines
les biologistes américains ont isolé des
cellules puis in vitro grâce à un gène
ils les ont empêchés de se détruire puis
grâce à un autre gène
ils les ont rendu immortel puis grâce à
un troisième
ils les ont fait pousser littéralement
meilleur sera notre connaissance sur les
mécanismes de transformation cellulaire
in vitro meilleures seront les
possibilités de pouvoir développer de
nouvelles drogues thérapeutique
après l'observation in vitro le travail
des chercheurs va se poursuivre sur des
expérimentations animales avant d'en
venir à l'heure on peut faire la
comparaison avec le virus du sida hiv la
multithérapie aulas bio trithérapie sont
du coup plus efficace que monothérapie
parce qu'on touche plusieurs cibles donc
on peut penser que la partie de ces
expériences
on pourrait développer des thérapies
plus efficaces
ce que l'espoir c'est d'en venir dans
quelques années à une trithérapie génie
mais ce n'est aujourd'hui qu'un espoir
alors jean vanier bonsoir est-ce qu'on a
raison de parler de découverte
fondamentale
oui parce que vous savez que le
processus de cancérisation sert passer
d'une cellule normale une cellule
cancéreuse
ça prend 10 15 20 ans naturellement et
on n'arrivait pas chez l'être humain à
savoir toutes les étapes on n'arrive pas
à le démontrer pour la première fois on
va avoir un outil qui va permettre de
comprendre comment petit à petit une
cellule qui a priori a un aspect normal
deviennent cellules malignes et ça c'est
un phénomène était étonnamment important
parce qu'on va pouvoir analyser avoir
des instruments de mesure de toutes les
étapes de toutes les séquences ils
savaient des applications concrètes dans
la prévention du cancer par exemple
alors pour les traitements de on a
aujourd'hui des chimiothérapies qui font
des progrès chaque jour et on n'aura
peut-être pas d'une grande nouveauté
dans ce domaine en revanche ce qu'on
vous dise effectivement pour la
prévention et la prévention peut-être de
ce qu'on appelle des états précancéreux
vous savez on sait par exemple que
certaines certains polypes par exemple
de l'intestin
certaines lésions du sein peuvent elles
sont qui sont pros réputé entre
guillemets bening peuvent au bout de dix
ou quinze ans devenir des tumeurs
malignes donc sur les capable d'analyser
à temps ce qui leur manque
qu'est ce qui a pu se passer comme
défaut et quand j'ai ce défaut on pourra
probablement les empêcher de venir
conscience si je prends un exemple c'est
un peu comme si vous avez une voiture
qui aurait des pneus un peu lisse des
freins qui marche très mal les
essuie-glaces un peu défaillant et des
phares sur le point de s'éteindre
vous irez finalement à l'accident mais
si on est capable ou fait en quelque
sorte un contrôle technique et devoirs
en amont on se passe l'erreur qu'est ce
qui va mal on peut imaginer que dans
quelques années on en aura les outils de
la thérapie génique
c'est à dire des substances de
remplacement qui permettront un état pré
cancéreux de ne pas évoluer vers un
cancer il faut être très prudent parce
que ce sera peut-être dans de très
longues années seulement merci jean
daniel et merci d'attendre de vacances
pour vous expliquer tout ça
bison futé en est convaincu ce sera le
week-end le plus chargé de l'été à un
vendredi rouge partout en france un
samedi noir en province avec 7 millions
d'automobilistes attendu les routes
s'annoncent très chargés surtout dans le
sens des départs seul conseil de la
sécurité routière
évitez absolument le samedi 13 mille
policiers et gendarmes sont mobilisés
les contrôles vont être renforcés et sur
les autoroutes les sociétés s'apprêtent
à gérer au mieux la fluence reportage
sur l'autoroute a10 entre tours et
poitiers de françois privat et de
philippe ridet
sur l'a10 au péage de sorigny au sud de
tours depuis neuf ans céleste vie le
grand chassé croisé de juillet août
loin des plages dans sa petite cabine
d'agents receveur sera classée noire au
corps on va la patiente et on va
s'occuper d'aller shooter à tour départs
et retours cumulés
on estime à 250 mille le nombre de
véhicules attendus sur ce week-end
classé rouge rouge également pour la
société qui exploite l'autoroute
le pass on a un effectif de 30 personnes
à 100 personnes et avons multiplié les
effectifs par plus de trois en multiples
les effectifs en plus de 3 effectivement
donc pour ce faire nous nous avons
recours à du personnel saisonnier elle
d'urgence elle d'urgence essayez de la
gendarmerie dans la vienne au sud de
châtellerault très bien merci
ici en permanence deux gendarmes gère
tous les appels d'urgence les dépannages
comme les secours en cas d'accident sur
l'autoroute trois patrouilles tous les
50 km prête à intervenir pour rappeler
quelques règles de sécurité en cas de
panne sur la bande d'arrêt d'urgence ou
pour signaler tout oubli de ceinture ce
week-end les gendarmes seront avant tout
visible avec ou sans radar c'est la
prévention active sur le fret de voir
des patrouilles en armure y soient
installés dans une soute cours ou
les patrouilles sur la bande d'arrêt
d'urgence m'a fait réfléchir et
penser qu'on est bien là le départ des
aoûtiens sur cette partie de la 10
durant le mois de juillet on a dénombré
plus d'un million deux cent mille
véhicules légers avec un nombre
d'accidents corporels en nette
régression par rapport à l'année
dernière
et du côté des gars le week-end
s'annonce là aussi douloureux avec 2
million de voyageurs attendus dans les
seules gares parisiennes un record pour
rejoindre les gares la sncf vous
recommande d'utiliser les transports en
commun et toute cette agitation estivale
va se faire sur fond de beau temps et de
pollution le niveau 2 a été atteint en
seine-maritime cet après midi il a
surtout été pour la deuxième journée
consécutive dans le sud-ouest parisien
la vitesse maximale autorisée a été
diminuée sur les routes de l'essonne et
des yvelines cette pollution à l'ozone
est surtout localisé sur la forêt de
rambouillet
cela peut paraître paradoxal les
explications de dominique barrau et de
gilles jacquier et amp
la police n'a qu'à choisir tout le monde
ou presque est en excès de vitesse
car pollution oblige depuis ce matin la
barre est placée 20 km/heure en dessous
de la normale
j'en ai entendu parler matin à la radio
et tapait et les poteaux étaient très
bien
proche quand je n'ai pas fait attention
ils étaient auditionnés
cent trente deux kilomètres/heure [ __ ]
mais lui le nombre d'infractions seuls
les plus gros excès sont verbalisés
autre contrôle le pot d'échappement
aujourd'hui 1 à l'image mal réglée coûte
cher le volet les véhicules qui sont en
infraction
les conducteurs sont verbalisés enfin
des propriétaires sont verbalisés il
risque une amende de 450 francs et il ne
s'en tirent pas aussi bien que ça
puisque nous les obligeons à se
représenter à un contrôle après avoir
remis en état leurs véhicules comme le
révèlent les mesures d'airparif la
ceinture verte de paris récupère la
pollution de la capitale on a eu un
niveau d'information de 180 microgrammes
par les cubes ce qui est dû au transport
de la masse d'air qui qui contenait tous
les polluants émis au niveau de
l'agglomération parisienne sous le sous
l'effet du vent qui était de secteur
nord-est et tout c'est donc la masse
d'air vers vers ce secteur là
aujourd'hui
les vents soufflent du nord-est il y a
dix jours les vents opposé provoque est
au contraire des pics de pollution en
seine et marne
si la pollution de la ville est
directement responsable de la formation
d'ozone les régions rurales jour est
paradoxalement le rôle d'accélérateur
les émissions d'origine végétale par
exemple sont des sources d'émetteurs de
de composés organiques volatils et qui
est ça peut venir participer renforcer
la production dans ce cas-là local
d'ozone au niveau de ces zones
vu l'absence de vent et le soleil de
plomb airparif redoute demain une
extension de la pollution à l'ensemble
de l'île de france et c'est pour ces
raisons donc que les limitations de
vitesse seront maintenus demain
notamment dans le département des
yvelines le l'accident de canyoning en
suisse trois des dix neuf corps ont été
identifiés il s'agit notamment de deux
membres de l'équipe d'encadrement
les recherches se poursuivent pour
tenter de retrouver deux autres disparus
l'enquète s'annonce bien sûr difficile
difficile on sait simplement que la
noyade est la principale cause des wc
c'est ce qu'a révélé l'autopsié et l'on
s'interroge de plus en plus sur le
comportement de l'agent ce qui avait
organisé l'expédition sur place le
reportage de pierrick hurter et de
frédéric de la rue martin trappe prend
ses précautions
le juge chargé de l'enquêté c'est
entouré de policiers de guide de haute
montagne
il a tenu à se rendre lui-même dans le
torrent le débit revenu proche de la
normale le permettent enfin il veut
savoir il veut comprendre car l'ampleur
du drame a troublé les esprits
beaucoup de rumeurs circulent par
exemple plusieurs personnes affirme
aujourd'hui avoir croisé et avertit le
groupe des risques météo sur trois est
thomas que des personnes non frères qui
ont prétendu avoir réussi mais je peux
rien dire de plus concret de bars pubs à
la police a interrogé ces personnes et
moi je vais regarder le skipper se
rendre compte cela veut dire
reconstituer le trajet du goût
le juge d'instruction va chuter
plusieurs fois dans le torrent il
s'arrête longuement sur les rochers ou
ont été emportées les vitrines
il descend les passages les plus
escarpés en rappel les guides lui
explique les cordes de vie les mousses
côte on compare le niveau atteint par la
vague avec le niveau actuel il
ressortira de son expédition
impressionné on peut dire que je connais
maintenant l'endroit où s'est passé marc
si dans je dois dire que c'est très
impressionnant de voir la force de l'eau
mais il faut pas oublier que la
situation n'est pas la même pour
comprendre la catastrophe le juge devra
aussi se rendre beaucoup plus en amont
là où le sar ce bar prend sa source au
pied de la borne heures perdues dans les
nuages
ce massif est un cirque montagneux
lorsque l'orage a éclaté dans ce fond de
vallée le cirque s'est transformée en un
gigantesque entonnoir
comme le juge pour les professionnels de
la montagne veulent comprendre et bien
sûr les lieux
le photographe qui travaille avec
l'agent incriminé ne veut croire lui par
la fatalité
mon opinion personnelle qui est assez
claire je crois dans ce cas là c'est que
l'ol à monter beaucoup plus rapidement
que d'habitude si ce n'est pas que
simplement une grande vague est arrivée
sur ces gens qui étaient tout à fait pas
préparé pour ça dans la vallée toutes
les agences qui vivent des sports de
montagne ont stoppé leur activité
heinz loosli est le principal concurrent
du club adventure lui le jour de
l'accident avait fait un autre choix
je n'y suis pas allé ce jour là parce
que le temps des débats et des hallyday
on a réagi et on n'a pas accepté les
gens qui voulaient faire cette sortie
les secouristes passent ce soit encore
le lac au filet une recherche de
disparus
thierry kurt et vous êtes sur place une
cérémonie je crois est prévue dans les
jours qui viennent en hommage aux
victimes
et puis robes et pour l'instant les
rescapée de l'expédition doit se tenir à
la disposition de la justice
effectivement tout c'est tous ces
rescapés toutes ces victimes également
sont toutes de nationalité américaine
néo zélandaises et australiennes ou
suisse elles sont toutes regroupées dans
un seul chalet à une quinzaine de
kilomètres d'ici et puis elle téléphone
elle passe encore beaucoup de temps avec
leur famille au téléphone justement un
psychologue est aussi dans les murs pour
les aider et pour l'instant aucun
contact avec la presse car les auditions
ne sont pas terminées on a vu également
aujourd'hui beaucoup d'officiels leur
rendre visite
et puis la région d'interlaken a
absolument tenu à annuler les festivités
prévues pour la fête nationale suisse
qui devait se tenir le 1er août
par égard pour les victimes merci
thierry en autriche est une coulée de
boue qui a tué une personne et qui en a
blessé trois autres la nuit dernière une
coulée de 200 mètres de long sur 100 m
de large qui a été déclenchée là aussi
par un orage très violent
deux chalets ont également été détruits
les affaires de dioxine continue en
belgique 175 nouveaux élevages ont été
bloqués par le gouvernement belge qui a
décidé par ailleurs de détruire tous les
stocks de porc de boeuf et de volaille
soupçonnés d'être contaminés
la forte demande de lunettes spéciales
pour regarder
éclipse du 11 août donne des idées aux
fraudeurs c'est ainsi qu'en bulgarie
les autorités ont vu affluer un grand
nombre de lunettes de contrebande le
problème c'est qu'elle ne présage en
rien les yeux des dangers du soleil
en france la direction de la répression
des fraudes intensifie ses contrôles et
vérifient que les lunettes gratuites ou
non qui sont distribués soit bien agréée
aux normes cee marie-pierre samitier et
claude barnier dans la région de
versailles plus de 50 contrôles comme
celui ci ont déjà eu lieu
nous procédons à un contrôle sur les
lunettes les clips le contrôle porte
donc sur la conformité donc je vérifie
qu effectivement sur la mouture en
carton on voit bien le ceo qui veut une
présomption de conformité du produit
également les références de l'organisme
certificateur obligatoire également les
conseils d'utilisation de ces lunettes
attention aux rayures des rayures qui
pourraient être occasionnés par cette
agrafes et qui rendrait ses lunettes
inutilisable la demande des
consommateurs est très forte depuis
lundi de 150 dans la semaine la chez les
opticiens 6 millions de paires sont même
offerte par l'association pour
l'amélioration de là vue pour vérifier
qu'elles sont efficaces
il suffit de regarder un coin est
indécent d'une lampe halogène et je vais
les lunettes qui protège d'ailleurs
parfaitement la totalité de la partie
qui sert à regarder et si je doit
percevoir uniquement un point quand des
sens avec ce système qui sera de couleur
bleue très pâle et voilà les mêmes
rayons sans les lunettes
prudence donc car quelques secondes
suffiront pour brûler vos yeux si vous
regardez les clips ce en face sans
protection et puisque nous parlons de
contrefaçon et de contrebande les
douaniers du havre ont saisi 36 millions
de cigarettes marlboro contrefaites
elle arrivait de chine et devait
normalement repartir vers les canaries
l'ensemble de ces cigarettes
représentent au total d'une valeur
marchande d'environ 36 millions de
francs l'actualité économique en france
c'est toujours la grande bataille
boursière qui oppose la bnp à la société
générale et à paribas le dénouement
approche et les attaques se multiplient
c'est ainsi que la société générale a
porté plainte aux états unis contre la
bnp et que les trois banques rivalisent
la presse à coude annonces publicitaires
et de bilan élogieux sert il de vos
billets d'avion et didier renquet on
n'avait jamais vu autant de
publicitaires dans les banques qu'en ce
moment
stéphane fouks et l'un d'eux dans sa
mallette sa nouvelle pub pour la bnp
un message simple la bnp m paribas et la
société générale
objectif séduire les actionnaires de
l'adversaire je prends l'exemple il est
très simple il ya aujourd'hui dans le
monde une page de publicité outre la
colonne de gauche
nous avons mis un cochon symbole
universel de la tirelire et de nos
économies et dans lequel on fait
apparaître la prime que nous proposons
aux actionnaires de la société générale
s'ils apportent leurs titres à la bnb
riposte de l'adversaire une pleine page
couleur dans le quotidien la tribune
tarif 250 mille francs bruts à la une du
journal libération cette petite
publicité pour la bnp environ 60000
francs surenchère aussi dans les
arguments on dénigre le concurrent en
soulignant par exemple la baisse du
cours de son action
la guerre des pubs fait chaque jour le
bonheur des journaux surtout de leur
régie publicitaire dans ce combat de
papier les trois banques ont déjà
dépensé 181 millions de francs un
chiffre d'affaires sur une campagne
telle que celle ci je pense pouvoir dire
que l'histoire de publicité financière
c'est effectivement une première dans
chaque camp on cherche à minimiser le
coût de l'opération
ça va coûter finalement publicité le
même prix que le lancement d'une marque
de café on va dépenser dans cette
période à peu près 45 millions de francs
ça représente 30 centimes par action les
actionnaires ont jusqu'à lundi prochain
pour passer leurs ordres et le 17 août
on saura qui de l'alliance société
générale paribas ou de la bnp a remporté
la victoire
pendant ce temps à paris la bourse a
fortement reculé aujourd'hui l' indice
cac 40 a même fini sur une baisse de 2
67% c'est le contrecoup de la
publication de mauvais indices aux états
unis qui font craindre une hausse des
taux d'intérêt américains et puis
pendant l'été le gouvernement poursuit
ses grandes restructurations
industrielles dominique strauss kahn et
alain richard ont annoncé aujourd'hui la
recomposition du capital de framatome et
de thomson csf une recomposition qui
devrait permettre d'une part la
constitution
grand pôle nucléaire européen autour de
framatome et de la cogema et puis
d'autre part la constitution d'un grand
groupe électronique civils et militaires
en rapprochant alcatel et thomson en
politique les verts ne décolère pas
après le mini remaniement d'hier
dominique voynet semble qu'il n'en a
rien laissé paraître au dîner donné par
lionel jospin hier soir à matignon
mais noël mamère lui parle de camoufler
de bras d'honneur de couleuvres avalées
il n'est quand même pas question que les
verts quittent le gouvernement
même s'ils n'ont pas obtenu le
remaniement qu'il souhaitait à
l'étranger hubert védrine le chef de la
diplomatie française vient d'arriver en
algérie une visite de deux jours qui
doit permettre de réchauffer les
relations entre paris et alger les
autorités algériennes attendent donc des
gestes de la part du gouvernement
français comme la réouverture de
certains consulats et à terme le retour
d'air france alger sur place le
reportage de thierry thuillier et de
maryse richard il était venu à alger en
97 points une réunion des pays
méditerranéens
mais cette fois ci la visite d'hubert
védrine prend une toute autre
signification
la relance des relations bilatérales
singulièrement dégradées accueilli reçu
par son homologue armes est attaf hubert
védrine va entrer dans le vif du sujet
demain où l'attend sa première rencontre
avec le président bouteflika entretien
abordé avec un nouvel état d'esprit
je me retrouve aujourd'hui à alger dans
un contexte nouveau prometteur que
permet de penser que la france et
l'algérie pour pouvoir relancer
intensifier leurs relations sur tous les
flancs situation un nouvel optimisme
esprit constructif
à l'issue du premier entretien ce soir
algériens et français passent obama dit
très bonne il ya c'est vrai beaucoup pas
faire devant l'ambassade de france la
file d'attenté pour les visas est
toujours aussi longue
les conditions de délivrance du précieux
sésame on peut changer malgré des
aménagements récents cette année près de
200 mille visas devrait être vivre alors
on attend beaucoup de la réouverture des
consulats difficile on se souvient de
tout du sud de l'est et l'ouest du
centre et a cassé le consulat à peshawar
seulement déjà qu'il trouvera
le
pensent-ils annaba oran jeu ça va
permettre aux jambes se disperser un peu
partout mais me paraît que ce soit les
centres culturels ventre et auraient
ouvert mais jusqu'à présent ces rumeurs
le centre culturel français et le consul
à alger comme toutes les représentations
françaises dans le pays de fermer leurs
portes depuis plus de quatre ans que
l'algérie attend désormais du concret de
la visite d'hubert védrine les algériens
elle en fait on finit avec ce qu'ils ont
vécu comme un isolement forcé une mise
en quarantaine
ce serait pour eux le signe le plus
tangible que la politique abelaziz
bouteflika est la bonne
et cette visite d'hubert védrine devrait
être suivie prochainement de voyage de
jacques chirac et de lionel jospin au
kosovo madeleine albright le secrétaire
d'état américain a été acclamé à
pristina est là pourtant exhorté les
albanais à cesser les violences contre
les serbes sous peine de se priver du
soutien de la communauté internationale
aura t-elle dit mais elle a quand même
embrassé hachey mme tall ship chef
politique de look tchèque a en revanche
un peu plus tard l'accueil et et vous
allez le voir beaucoup plus froid du
côté des serbes elle a été prise à
partie lors de la visite d'un monastère
orthodoxe madeleine albright à fulbright
à n'a pas renouvelé ses critiques sur la
lenteur de la mise en place des
structures de l'onu au kosovo mais ces
questions seront sans doute au centre de
la conférence qui s'ouvre à sarajevo
bill clinton jacques chirac tony blair
entre autres ils sont attendus demain
pour promouvoir ce qu'on appelle le
pacte de stabilité dans les balkans
un sommet qui devrait consacrer
l'isolément de slobodan milosevic a dit
bill clinton le président américain qui
vient d'apprendre qu'il devait payer 90
mille dollars d'amendé pour outrage à la
justice dans le cadre de la sphère paula
jones le football et la reprise du
championnat de france de première
division ce week end une première
division qui mûrit sur le plan financier
pour rivaliser avec les championnats
d'angleterre ou d'italie
les grands clubs sont allés à la pêche
aux investisseurs c'est ainsi que
l'olympique lyonnais sponsorisé par
pathé et maintenant le club le plus
riche de france ses ambitions pour cette
année sont à la hauteur de son
recrutement
julien est riche on est olivier journée
l'olympique lyonnais adopte un nouveau
visage
le club s'est attaché les services de
sonny anderson un transfert record en
france 120 millions de francs
c'est le signe des temps nouveaux depuis
l'arrivée de groupe pathé qui a investi
100 millions dans le club
lyon possède le plus gros budget de
l'hexagone devant marseille et le psg
samedi sonny anderson ne jouera pas la
première journée du championnat
légèrement blessés ils se contentent
pour le moment de simples jeux mais le
brésilien sait bien que les spectateurs
et dirigeants attendent beaucoup de lui
peu lui importe
il assume ta pas de raison de bava pas
de la pression si on n'a pas la pression
on n'a pas les performances
je crois que c'est ça le résultat est un
brin de foot d'espièglerie c'est la
ville de tunis
tony vairelles a quitté lens pour 50
millions de francs et un salaire
lyonnais de 800000 francs par mois vers
elle a perdu le nord mais n'a pas cédé
ses valeurs aujourd'hui il sait où sont
les siens moi je suis dione puisque je
porte déjà le maillot donc
j'ai envie de les porter haut et fort
les couleurs de mu ce maillot là jean
michel aulas président de l'ol le sait
avec anderson vers elle mais aussi
pierre laigle lyon on peut rêver à
condition de ne pas oublier les vertus
de l'humilité la ddt
le football est une science qui doit
permettre de se remettre en cause
rien est arrivé ce n'est pas parce que
lyon a fait des investissements
importants que des joueurs de très grand
talent sont ici que nous allons tout
gagner
le message du lyonnais a séduit les
spectateurs le club est passé de 14 me
l'a donné à 18 milles cette année le
stade sera sans doute 25 pour accueillir
montpellier un peu de fraîcheur
maintenant par ces périodes de grosse
chaleur il est en effet un endroit de
villégiature extrêmement frais auxquels
les français ne pensent pas beaucoup
c'est le réseau de canaux et de rivières
de notre beau pays
reportage sur le canal du midi avec jean
jacques dufour et blaise grenier
chants de l'eau en france il ya vraiment
tout ce qu'il faut 8500 km de voies
navigables
croyez moi l'été ça permet vraiment de
se mettre au fait quelqu'un
en effet si depuis cinq jours alors
c'est vrai ma france qui sont en
prévente rang des vacances de père
peinard où l'on navigue pas loin des
canards en pas une bonne manière de
rompre les amarres
le seul petit souci le passage des
écluses automatisé ou mécanisée avis aux
passagers pressés on est obligé de
s'arrêter andré c'est quoi une bonne
journée
combien de bateaux j'en ai oui mais
attention sur les canaux à l'heure du
déjeuner et dans la soirée c'est permet
ainsi on arrive après 19h30 on peut
passer l'éclusé à n'auront pas raison
alors je dois en parler plus riches il
ya un décalage de 20 minutes
tout bateau qui se présentait la minutes
avant la fermeture ne peut pas être
accusé sera écoulé
oh excusez moi vous êtes français et oui
anglais parce qu'elle est savoir
pourquoi mais sur les 160000 vacanciers
qui ont ainsi sillonné la france l'an
dernier 80 % étaient des touristes
étrangers
on se promène mais on fait pas du bateau
je ne m'en fais pas de meiway parce que
c'est trop cher et dit maintenant les
appétits retraités ben effet après j'en
fais pas partie tout ça le royaume quoi
qu'il en soit et pour ceux qui ont envie
de l'eau quelques infos sur le prix des
bateaux ça dépend du type de bateau
celui ci par exemple qui est un bateau
six places grand luxe et écoute entre
2000 et 6000 francs la semaine selon la
saison
on a des bateaux de gamme moyenne qui
vont entre 11000 on va dire 7000 et 11
mai franc en fin de saison la semaine
pour six personnes
il a besoin de permis ou pas non
absolument pas y'a pas besoin de permis
justement c'est pour ça qu'il ya autant
de monde maintenant qui se dirigerait
tourisme fluvial
vous pouvez conduire un bateau comme
celui-là sans permis
pour les marins d'eau douce la seule
restriction c'est la vitesse pas plus de
six kilomètres heure
alors monsieur
elle est pas belle la france des canaux
mais oui bien sûr elle incite à la
rêverie à la douceur au fil de l'eau on
peut laisser filer idéal pour les
stressés
voilà ça vous chante nous partons
maintenant pour le maroc sur le tournage
du nouveau film d'alexandre arcady un
film qui s'intitulera là bas une sorte
de retour aux sources pour ce metteur en
scène né en algérie et qui a choisi de
raconter l'actualité de son pays
le tournage bien sûr allié au maroc pour
des raisons évidentes
reportage de marie josée jouant et de
daniel lévy là bas comme nostalgie
là bas comme racine là bas c'est
l'algérie du cinéaste alexandre arcady
celle du coup de sirocco mais aussi
celle d'aujourd'hui qu'il a choisi de
retrouver pour son onzième film
troisième jour de tournage dans une
maison kabyle la mise en place se
termine il est 7 heures du matin ce
matin j'ai encore la preuve pour bois
mon café
antoine de caunes c'est pierre nivelles
une star le journal de 20h qui revient
30 ans après dans son pays natal pour
sauver des griffes du gia
amina la fille de la femme qu'il a
follement aimée adolescents raconte au
jour le jour a jamais voulu te les
envoyer
tu vas voir a dit des choses incroyables
sur les femmes d'algérie qu'on sera en
france y mènera les faire publier
elle découvre son pays natal meurtri par
par des combats terribles des massacres
terrible puisque rooney dans 94
le moment le plus extrême nous l'algérie
sans prévenir
et ils répondent à l'appel aux moments
forts du film lorsque le journaliste
découvre une maison kabyle où toute une
famille a été massacrée
pour le chef décorateur toni negri
également frère du réalisateur un moment
difficile on a violemment de leurs
reportages qui ont été faits sur sur les
sources et villages en kabylie etc
c'est comme ça vous ne partie sur pour
faire ce à quoi pour ici de donner le
dur de la réalité
d'autant plus concerné l'acteur algérien
samy nacery il n'est pas retourné en
algérie depuis 15 ans a voulu rentrer
mois alors qu'à l'image
tu vas être obligé de rentrer talent au
monde leur faut gagner et jimmy jimmy
j'ai dû mettre 3 4 minutes avant de
m'habituer aux décors arcady à vous
préciser que son film est avant tout une
belle histoire d'amour sur fond
policiers il semble toujours conduit par
le devoir de mémoire
je sais que c'est le genre de thème du
sont chères qui s'est bien traité et il
m'a semblé que dans dans ce film-là par
rapport au précédent que je connais de
lui avait quelque chose de ramasser de
concentrer et de définitif je sais pas
si on peut dire ça mais tout le cac
comme si les films qui l'avait fait
précédemment devait nécessairement
conduire assure et quand on lui demande
si avec là bas il va tourner la page de
l'algérie le cinéaste répond qu'on reste
toujours pétri de ses racines
non
le festival d'avignon ne s'est jamais
aussi bien portée pour sa 53e édition la
fréquentation est en hausse de 15%
et pour clore cette édition on a fait
appel à maria steve coleman et son tango
valse et tango frey benêt et france
vaillant et pas de tango sur une musique
classique
la chorégraphe anna-maria steadman n'a
pas pu résister à la tentation
avec sa troupe d'une vingtaine
d'artistes elle est venu jusqu'ici pour
nous offrir pour la première fois et
dans la cour d'honneur
un message qui en dit long sur
l'histoire de son pays l'argentine ce
spectacle de jongle avec les genres
fusionne les styles avec volupté et
mélange donc asie les cultures avec
élégance
je pense que les cultures se mélangent
de plus en plus aux gens clément
benneteau va seulement avec
l'immigration mais aussi avec internet
c'est montrer au travers de tous les
moyens de casser ce phénomène de notre
époque un géant lui regretté falling
down et communication étrennée par la
foule qui c'est l'encré qui pense une
folle farandole je suis encore trop loin
et je crise mais point maudissant la
foule qui me vont
l'homme qu'elle m'avait donné que je
n'ai jamais l'homme et la femme ou
plutôt le masculin et le féminin
voici la base de cette chorégraphie qui
glisse de l'un à l'autre avec attirance
et répulsion
avec l'un des plus grands bandonéoniste
du monde l'amérique du sud fait danser
sur les planches d'avignon bien plus
qu'une oeuvre originale une véritable
mise en mouvement de l'identité
argentine
voilà on arrive à la fin de ce journal
je vous en rappelle les principaux
titres une étape capitale dans la lutte
contre le cancer des chercheurs
américains découvrent les phases de
transformation d'une cellule normale en
cellules cancéreuses
un événement phare dans la recherche qui
devrait se traduire à long terme par
l'arrivée de nouveaux traitements
et puis un week-end de tous les dangers
pour bison futé 7 millions
d'automobilistes sont attendus sur les
routes pour un chassé croisé qui
s'annonce difficile pour éviter les
ennuis laisser passer le samedi c'est le
slogan et le conseil de la sécurité
routière voit dans un instant la météo
ce sera nathalie rihouet suivi du point
route de valérie maurice 20h55 les
nouveaux mondes présentée par antoine de
maximy le dernier journal vers zéro et
redit
frédéric rota demain à 7h50 pour son
dernier rendez-vous dans les 4 vérités
marie pierre farkas recevra le député
européen jean charles marchiani à 13h
vous retrouverez bien sûr rachid arhab
et carole gaessler à 20 heures philippe
lefait quant à moi je ré l'immense
plaisir de vous retrouver lundi soir aux
alentours de 20h bonne soirée bon
week-end et bonne route
sur france 2 bien sûr
je